Cindy, welcome to the show. Thanks for
having me. I am very excited to dig in.
And a, I thought we could start. Can I
in media arrests as they say in novels,
we start right in the
middle of the action.
So we're going to bounce all
over the place. As I always do.
Jp Morgan Healthcare Conference,
I've heard some sort of murmurs about
stories and getting attention or people to
focus. Could you please describe
for folks what happened?
Awesome. So biggest conference in
all of healthcare I get invited in.
I have eight minutes do or die.
So proud of this opportunity again in
front of the room. You can imagine.
Here's me in hot pink,
head to toe.
I started to talk about women in sex
and the whole room starts to giggle.
I can feel this giggle
going off or you know,
across the crowd and I'm panicking like
watching the clock count down so I can
remember reaching to my laptop.
That's where in as fast as I can to a
slide that was just brain scan studies.
Studies of women with this condition
versus women without were in black and
white. We could see there's a biological
basis to women's lack of desire for sex.
So I turned,
I put the slide up,
I turned and pointed long enough for
it to be uncomfortable for everybody.
I went silent. And when I
did that, I said, are you
looking at what I'm looking at?
Cause I'm here.
I'm just here to talk about the biology
of sex for women is an important lesson
for me. If at what I was going to
have to do to make people focus.
You let the silence do the work.
It was uncomfortable.
I figured it was long enough for
it to be uncomfortable for me,
which was a fair trade for them.
Have you made me really uncomfortable if
they started giggling and wouldn't pay
attention?
Silence. Yeah. It's uh,
it's so powerful. It's so,
so powerful.
And I remember advice I was given at
one point while I was given that advice
first by someone named cal Fussman is
a master interviewer when he was going
over some transcripts from this podcast
in the early days. And he's like, no,
you're too fast. Like you
don't leave gaps. Hmm. Uh,
and you don't have to save people, like
let the silence do the work. So I just, I,
I love that story. And so speaking
of letting the silence do the work,
I'm going to go silent for a
bit because I want to ask you
two questions that I'm might take a few
minutes to answer them and start with a
short one. What is your
favorite business and why? Hmm.
My favorite business of all is Wegmans,
which if anybody's from the northeast,
uh,
they appreciate this as a grocery store.
How can you get excited
about a grocery store?
I'm excited because
it's from my birthplace.
Rochester and I went there
every Sunday as a little girl.
Here's why I loved it because of the
incredible loyalty that they instilled.
How do you get folks that are cashiers
at the checkout line with jobs that may
seem relatively unexciting to show up
with unbridled enthusiasm for what they
do? So it opened years later
I moved my whole life, uh,
and it opened in the DC area and I went
the first day that Wegmans opened in DC
and I walked up and all of their employees
are standing outside holding their
hands above their head like a w
because they have a Wegmans pride,
the Wegmans way.
And I got to tell you that first date,
anybody in the entire DC metro area who'd
ever been to a Wegmans showed up and
stood in line to walk through this store.
I love them for being a private family
held business that has that kind of
loyalty and longevity of employees.
How do they instill that?
I mean is it's filtering for the right
employees who are prone to that to begin
with? Is it something else?
I mean how do they develop?
I think it is,
oh so simple.
I think it is their basic appreciation
for the people who show up and work for
them every day and they reward
them through the right incentives.
They reward them through the best
benefits. They help develop them,
they encourage them when they lose weight.
I mean there are all of these incentives
to their employees that make them truly
feel that appreciation from their
employer. And also I think, you know,
be proud to work there. They go home and
have pride in saying who they work for.
So I started studying businesses
I loved at a very young age.
I had a conversation with Frank Blake,
former CEO of home depot right here.
He's sitting where you are and who they
develop this orange apron cult as it was
sometimes referred to and the dedication
that some of these employee shows.
Incredible.
And his point was in one of these
systems they instilled was a positive
reinforcement by sharing stories on a
very regular schedule basis of kind of
stand out customer service.
And it doesn't have to be complicated.
I have to tell you, when I sold
my first business slate, yeah,
I sold it to a group that
was private equity back.
And I ran into one of those guys, uh, one
of the bankers years later, and he said,
that group you had,
they were almost cult like,
and I think he said it was sort of
one eyebrow raised like, hmm. They,
and I said, why thank you. That's the
guesses. Compliment I've ever received.
Uh, yeah, the apple way, not
the David Koresh way. Perfect.
Exactly.
So the next question,
which will seem odd to people listening
but will soon make more sense is it's
not really a question Irma.
I'll be polite and make it a question.
Could you please give me your three
minute commercial? Tell me about yourself.
Soup to nuts.
All right. Um, moved my entire childhood.
So every year from fourth to 12th
grade I was in a different school,
so I was the perpetual new kid.
I think what that did is
perfect my ability to stand
on the outside of the room
and look in and really listen,
understand motivations,
understand sort of the dynamic which
served me well later in life at the time I
went kicking and screaming.
Um,
I have a love that started very young
in life for what makes businesses great.
So as I went through college,
I was fortunate to have a great business
professor who really cultivated that in
me. So I'd have to report to her every
week what my favorite business was, why,
what were they doing differently?
And along that way made a unilateral
decision that I was going to go work for
Merck. So she thought I should
probably brought my options.
It wasn't such a slam dunk. I told her,
no, I'm going to work for Merck. Um,
they weren't hiring when I got a school,
but eight months later they were,
and I got the job, called her up a said,
I got that job that you said I might not.
And she said, great, we're going
out to dinner and you're buying.
So went to work from work,
started in Pharma because it was
fortune's most admired company.
That's why I went there
wanting to learn from the best.
I thought I would actually
take it elsewhere and apply it.
Didn't really think I was going to be
so fascinated with the science fell in
love with the science and the innovation,
what it could mean in people's lives.
Loved what Pharma had the capacity to do,
hated how they got it done
in the bigger companies.
So I made the leap went smaller,
smaller, smaller, smaller, um,
until I ultimately was maybe crazy
enough to start it for myself. Uh,
built two businesses both
in sexual health people say,
why say Irish Catholic of course.
Um,
so built a business late with the only
a long acting testosterone for men.
Uh, and that made me on the path of
watching this emergent science for women.
Um,
when the drug,
when this drug was put on the shelf
by the company that invented it,
I made a decision to stop it off
and take it on and got the, uh,
only ever drug approved, uh,
for sexual desire in women,
sold that business and
now as a pass through,
do nothing but spend my time reaching
my hand back and trying to get female
founders there to my kind of outcomes
faster than I got there myself.
That was really good.
And how many minutes
your listeners will know if I'd use my
spider sense. I think that was really,
really close.
So I'm very impressed and for people
who are wondering what the hell is Tim
doing? This is the oddest
interview have ever heard him, uh,
attempt to give it is because why?
What are the last two
questions have in common?
Why did I ask those two questions?
You asked those two questions because I
love to ask those questions of everybody
I interview cause I think that if
you'll just be quiet and listen, uh,
which you heard a little
bit from my background,
people will tell you a lot about
themselves and what their motivations are.
So that was always probably my initial
question and interviewing and figuring
out from people what they would
tell me about themselves. Okay.
What would you look for or what were,
were there any particular
sort of checkered flags?
Meaning fantastic or red flags?
Meaning hmm,
maybe not a good person to pick four.
Me, you know, it was
discomfort with change,
the lack of adaptability because in
my environments they were not the same
structure that they might
have been coming from.
They were going to have to be nimble,
have to move quickly to keep pace or I
always laid my cards on the table at the
end of interviews and said, here's
who we are, here's this culture. Um,
we both should lay our cards on the
table because six months from now I don't
want us to be unhappy with each other.
Um,
so I think I'm always listening for those
cues that would indicate a fit for my
environment and a,
and in it,
I think I was finding the people
with a love of businesses.
I often ask that question,
what is the business that you most admire?
Because they've got to have that passion.
I think particularly in small and startup,
you have to have a real love affair
with what it is that makes things tick.
What did you study in Undergrad business?
Yeah.
What did your business professor do
besides have you report back each week on
your favorite business of the week?
I think she just took a special interest.
I think she saw something there and
cultivated it so that she was pushing me.
So not only did she push me with the
assignment that was above and beyond what
she was asking of everybody else,
but I think she also tortured
me a little bit with, um,
the doubt to see if I would push through
it. You know, when I said to her,
I'm going to go work for Merck,
she's like, wow, I don't know.
Their science grades aren't that good.
I mean she really sort of pushed back.
Like it wasn't such a sure thing. So she
was constantly setting the bar for me.
Did she know, I don't know if you had
a chance to ask her, but once she,
did she genuinely think that you would
have trouble getting the job or was it a
Yoda trick to get you to
stubbornly then pursue,
pursue it twice as hard?
100% of stubborn trek.
Yeah,
and I think she knew that I have sort
of a healthy chip on my shoulder of
proving it. Um, so she was definitely
pushing right at that button, um,
of, you know, go out there and
prove it. So yeah. Very clever.
So how does one start a Pharma
company without a Pharma background?
Well, Pharma background and that I'd
been in the industry for a long time.
So had the right, you know, contacts
had the industry experience. Yes.
Without the scientific backgrounds,
right. Surround yourself with it.
Extraordinary scientific team.
I feel like I've learned at the hands of
some of the best in science and I think
I've always brought a lens to it of,
you know, what would work in the market.
We were sort of a magical pairing
because many times in science you can get
enamored in the lab with
youngs and not look out,
tried to what's really going to
work in the mainstream. So it was,
it was a lot about having just
a great team. How did you pick,
and I can play a doctor on TV now
or at least think I can,
people's ear buds if they,
that's right.
How did you end up choosing the, you
said long acting testosterone. So, uh,
paint a picture for us.
Well,
I mean sure because we can certainly get
into testosterone and like HP Pta and
all this fun stuff up,
but I don't,
I don't want to bore some segment of my
population, uh, of listeners to death,
although I'm fascinated by, so we
probably will get into it. But the,
how did you end up choosing that?
Right. So you have, you want to start,
did it start with finding the opportunity
and then I want to start a company or
do you decide I want to start a company
now let me try to find that product.
Yup.
I wanted to start my own company,
so I felt like I had a hypothesis that,
and if you don't mind me asking,
how old were you at the time
or where were you in touch?
And I know that I was in my early
thirties at that time. Got It. Oh,
when I started it and I had had
one sort of career experience,
it was very informative. So I'd been
at a company that was acquired in this.
They had been gobbled up by somebody who
gobbled up a lot and then they had to
integrate them and I
got to be on that team.
So I got this sort of put
together of the perfect company.
That was a great career moment for me.
Um, and then I got to go apply it in,
in doing my own. And the reason I
did it is that for that same reason,
I love Pharma for what it can do at
three m in the morning. If you're sick,
you love Pharma. Yeah. In the
light of day you probably don't.
And it's because it is an industry
that has a certain reputation.
I thought there was a way to do it better.
And I had the hypothesis that here
I am driven and succeeding in these
environments, but totally uninspired
to have to be other people like me.
What if I got them together,
gave them permission to do it on
their own terms and that was slate.
I named my company Slade on purpose,
clean slate. We were going to do it,
we were going to do it our way and it
was to go out and find a diamond in the
rough and asset that had been overlooked.
I loved the category.
I love sexual medicine.
I'm a card carrying member of
the sexual medicine society.
Who knew there was that there is other,
it makes me popular cocktail parties.
I'd like whip it out. No
I it, there really is,
this is a society and it's because like
actually our understanding there has
really come much more recently.
Like it's a relatively new field and yet
we're learning such interesting things
and it's in conditions that,
you know,
you might not lose your life from them,
but you will lose your life as you
know it when you're affected by these
dysfunctions. So found, um,
this inventor who had the only FDA
approved long acting testosterone and
interestingly,
how do you find someone like that
you'd think that like in a,
in a world of some of Pharma discovery
that the bones would have been picked
clean?
Yes. Okay. So this is a great story.
So a scientist that I knew from previous
company was quoted in an article.
This gentleman reached out to
him. He said, I don't really,
I don't know anything about this space,
but I know somebody who's
really interested in it.
Commercialize was a very fortuitous sort
of introduction and couldn't believe
that this had been overlooked.
The reason it had been overlooked is that
almost of this product was being used
off label,
meaning that not for its indication
was being used interestingly in women.
So my journey started very
early in this use for libido.
It was testosterone and
it was a pellet. So, uh,
it was put it long acting put under the
surface of the skin release testosterone
over of sort of four to six
month window. Yeah. So I,
so here's me looking at it
going, hmm. First of all,
it should be used by urologists in
men. I did it, this crossover analysis.
Only one neurologist in
the country was using it.
So I thought this would be a great
business to build and frankly,
the delivery system is better than
what's available on the market today.
If I thought of something that was custom
made for men, they have to remember,
I big brothers, I'm used to
being around guys, you know,
they can be sitting on the beach burning
bright red and they still won't put
sunscreen on or rubbed something on.
And the most common application for
testosterone at the time were gels.
So this was like,
Hey,
can you remember to show up
three times a year to the doctor?
Yeah, yeah. All right.
So the inventor reaches out to your
friend, the scientist who says,
I can't help you, but maybe my friend
Kat. And that's how it starts. Uh,
and the, uh, so the pellet, how do they
know, I'm thinking of, for instance,
like trembling, which is used in
cattle in some cases also popular,
some power lifters and so on, a who do
not use it in pellet form, but how is it,
how is it administered or how
is it put into the patient?
So put in, in an in office procedure at
the end of it, it requires a bandaid. Um,
so there's a device, a Trocar, you go
just under the surface of the skin,
set it underneath the skin, put
a bandaid on. And it was, yeah.
And for your urologists who are
surgeons, this, you know, in,
in office procedure was very simple.
And the great news is it was half
the price of anything on the market.
So everybody was winning in this equation.
Why was it half the price?
Just because of the purpose for me.
Cause you set the pricing less costly
because you are comparing it to other
modes of administration which
require more visits. Tense. It's not,
no, it was just the market
positioning. Yeah. Hmm.
Fascinating.
What was the,
I have sort of a belief system around
that and Pharma about drug pricing.
And so it was important to me to do that.
We were making great money building a
great business and we were doing just fine
at that cost.
Right, right. You don't
need a 500 million. Yeah,
exactly. Uh, yes. And as, as we
may, we may or may not talk about,
some people get into a lot of trouble
for that. Rightfully so. Yeah.
Uh, what other questions do you like to
ask when you're interviewing people that,
are there any other questions
that you find yield, uh, are,
are worth the effort that
are particularly helpful or,
or other approaches to hiring?
I'm going to go back to silence.
Isn't that I'm going to go back to you.
I do more listening than asking.
I asked the one open ended question and
try to see where they'll take me cause I
think I'm getting a lot of insights
into who they are and by doing that,
so I don't think they're,
I don't think there are magical questions.
I think there's ways to tease out
cultural fit and that is so important.
I care much less about the
resume. Um, the quality, you know,
everybody wants to come
in and impress you.
They haven't really hit your
doorstep unless they have the credit.
I think to be in there
interviewing for the position.
So I feel like it's my job to really
tease out that cultural fit so that we're
both happy with each other.
So culture can mean a lot of things too.
Yeah.
To two different people in
this particular case. Uh,
and you mentioned the adaptability,
which in a,
in a small startup especially,
I mean,
you're gonna learn a lot of hats
in those heads. Make Change. She,
you need someone who is adaptable.
What else were you looking for
and what did it mean to you?
Six things, so minor, minor,
pretty specific looking for, well,
let me say overarching.
I'm looking for people who wake up
everyday and make deliberate choices.
It's all a choice, right?
How you go through life.
And mine were my six where they
had to choose to be an owner,
maybe highly motivated by that ownership.
Um, they had to choose to be bold.
We're going to make decisions
a little differently.
They had to choose to be quirky because
I needed them to feel that permission to
be individual in my environment.
Most of them are coming out
of environments in which
we, we beat like, you know,
sameness into people and
homogenize the whole group. Um,
they did choose to be learning. That's
fundamental to me even as I invest today.
So important to watch what
people do to learn every day. Um,
choose to be family. Uh, because
we were going to be a small,
tight knit group and they had
to choose to be appreciative.
And I think that that is
how you go through life. You
know, what is your attitude?
Do you sort of marvel at the
opportunity you have to make impact.
Um, so those were my six
choices I was looking for.
How do you avoid false positives in the
sense that if you ask someone or if you
lay out, if you say to
them, these are the six
because it doesn't,
you're,
you're listening to this story that
shows that I think exposes those values.
But if you ask somebody that, like if you
choose to be quirky, uh, sure, I cheat.
I mean it, you know, that's a, you're not
going to get, I think the right response.
I think you have to know your
core, who you are and who fits. Um,
and then I think you have
to ask the questions.
I will say there is one other question
I do always ask and I ask how was the
very first way you ever made money?
Oh, I like that. That's a really good one.
And, and if they can't, they never,
if they can't tell me, you know,
I put like flyers in the mailboxes in
the neighborhood and said odd jobs called
me or if they are like, wow, you know, my
first job out of college was they're out.
They don't have that sort of
mentality that's going to fit
one of, one of my friends, um,
Brian Johnson who has done a whole
host of very impressive things,
he was the founder,
I don't think he had a cofounder,
but let's just say one of the
founders to be safe of Braintree,
which then sold for a whole
lot of money. And, uh,
when entrepreneurs come to him,
because he invests quite a lot now and
they say they want to start something,
he'll ask them, is that an
itch or is that like, is it,
is it an itch or is it a burn? And, uh,
and then he'll take them down
that discussion to assess like,
do you really have the sticktuitiveness
and the stubbornness and just the,
it can't be any other way with me to
actually make it through this because it's
not going to be all.